[تصفيق]
تصمت النيران او هكذا يفترض فثم اتفاق
اخيرا لوقف اطلاق النار بين اسرائيل
والفصائل الفلسطينيه كان مصدر قد قال
للجزيره ان وسط التهدئه قدم صيغه جديده
لوقف متبادل لاطلاق النار في غزه وان
الصيغه الجديده تتضمن وقف استهداف
المدنيين وقصف منازلهم طالما ان المقاومه
تراكم قوتها هذه الضمانه الوحيده امامنا
ونحن نتوقع كما حدث السابق كما تقول نتوقع
ان اسرائيل ممكن ان ياتي اي لحظه وتدير
ظهرها لاي اتفاق
لكن بغض الطرف عن التفاصيل فحديث الساعه
المحتوم عن التطبيق على الارض
يتساءل متابعون للمشهد الله منذ ايام عن
طرق تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
ليس معروفا ايضا كيف سيتم التاكد من
التزام الجانبين بما ورد في نص اتفاقهما
وهل ثمه اليه واضحه لذلك لا يبدو الامر
يسيرا بالنظر الى الفتره التي استغرقتها
جهود ومحاولات التوصل لتهدئه هل الامر
مختلف هذه المره قد لا يتوافق هذا التوجه
مع نهج التصعيد العسكري الذي اطلقه
الاحتلال في قطاع غزه دون مبرر الامنيين
مباشر بل مع تلويحه المستمر كذلك بنقل
المواجهه الى مستويات اخرى
لكن ابرام اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار لا يمكن
فصله عن المشهد السياسي والامني في الداخل
الاسرائيلي ثم ضغوط بورست لا شك على
ائتلاف نتنياهو اليميني كي يضع حدا لما
بدا في البدء حتى في نظر المعارضه
الاسرائيليه عمليه صحيحه وناجحه لكنها
ابانت مع الوقت عن كلاف باهظه لا احد في
اسرائيل مستعد كما يبدو للاستمرار في
دفعها ربما كانت تصعيد في غزه واستئناف
عمليات اغتيال قاده المقاومه رضوحا من
نتنياهو لعوتات المتطرفين في حكومته بما
يحفظ تماسكها وربما سعى حقا لترميم قوه
ردع اسرائيل الاخذه في التاكل لكن محللين
في اسرائيل يرجحون الا تكون مكاسب نتنياهو
من خطوته على قدر توقعاته
فلا يبرا من كل متاعبه الداخليه من خلال
تغريب الاجنده الامنيه وتصدير ازماته
الداخليه بل تجده في المقابل مدفوعا من
النخب السياسيه والاعلاميه وحتى من الشارع
لانهاء التصعيد العسكري
ستجد الاكثر نقبه المتاثرين في مستوطنات
غلاف غزه من رد المقاومه القوي والمنسق
وكذا المستشعرين للاعباء الاقتصاديه
المتولده عن التصعيد ولخسائر اخرى اكبر قد
يتكبدونها اذا طالت المواجهه او اتسعت
رقعتها حكومه نتنياهو الائتلافيه احرص من
هؤلاء جميعا كما يبدو على تلف حرب من ذلك
القبيل